kampf um die kanzlerkandidatur armin
laschet und markus söder ringen um
unterstützung in der bundestag in der
unionsfraktion bundes notbremse in
deutschland das kabinett beschließt
einheitliches schärfere bonus regeln
fürs ganze land und nächste rückschlag
beim impfen der hersteller johnson &
johnson verschiebt nach thrombose fällen
die lieferungen nach europa
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem dienstag
norbert lehmann ist auch dabei für den
sport alles schön wie beim tor von mio
der kampf um die kanzlerkandidatur in
der union ist in vollem gange seit vier
stunden präsentieren sich die
kontrahenten armin laschet und markus
söder vor der unionsfraktion im
bundestag und nutzen offenbar die bühne
auch für sticheleien viele abgeordnete
drängen darauf dass sich die beiden
schnell einigen sonst schade dies der
union im wahlkampf aus berlin andreas
huppert den aufschlag machte markus
söder bei der erste der beiden
kanzlerkandidaten bewerber auf dem weg
in die bundestagsfraktion von cdu und
csu ein statement für die wartenden
journalisten gab es nicht am ende wird
alles gut
das hofft sicherlich auch armin laschet
der zwar auch wenig auskunftsfreudig war
zumindest aber verriet wie er die
mitglieder der unionsfraktion von sich
überzeugen will
gute argumente braucht denn hinter den
verschlossenen türen des plenarsaals
bluten die beiden bewerber aus wien die
abgeordneten für den geeigneten
kanzlerkandidaten halten
gestern hatten sich die jeweiligen
parteispitzen für söder beziehungsweise
laschet ausgesprochen jetzt herrscht
eine pattsituation
es geht heute auch einfach darum dass
beide noch mal die gelegenheit haben
auch mit der gesamten
fraktionsgemeinschaft nicht nur mit dem
geschäftsführenden fraktionsvorstand zu
reden das ist auch so weit in ordnung
oder auch nicht denn die csu hofft dass
sich möglichst viele cdu abgeordnete für
söder stark machen hofft auf abgeordnete
die auf söders bessere umfragewerte
schielen so könnte dann die csu obwohl
die kleinere partei mit süder als
kanzlerkandidaten in den wahlkampf wir
wollen gemeinsam in den wahlkampf ziehen
wir wollen gemeinsam die stärken von cdu
und csu nutzen und deswegen ist es ein
prozess der team finden die mir gerade
erleben vor der team findung steht
allerdings der machtkampf um die
kanzlerkandidatur in der union und da
ist noch kein ende in sicht
fragen wir theo koll in berlin was hören
sie aus der fraktion wer von beiden
kommt besser an was zu hören es gab es
zahlreiche äußerungen für beide aber
offensichtlich mit klarer mehrheit der
wortmeldungen für markus söder und es
zeigt warum sie dann nicht zufällig die
fraktion als entscheidend für die
kanzlerkandidatur bezeichnet hatte
viele abgeordnete denken natürlich an
die bundestagswahl an ihren wahlerfolg
und schauen daher besonders aufmerksam
auf die umfragen und den aktuellen
normen vorsprung von söder vor laschet
wiederum hat söder attackiert nun
brauche keine ein-mann-show und fragt
sollte man denn jens spahn zum kanzler
machen
der war auch mal beliebtester politiker
und man sehe wie schnell sich das ändere
also nach zwei tagen offener
feldschlacht steht die union ziemlich
zerzaust da und jetzt ist die alles
entscheidende frage welches gremium
welcher schiedsrichter bekommt die
entscheidungshoheit entschieden werden
soll jedenfalls bis freitag so kommen
wie laschet vor wenigen minuten
spannende woche dankeschön nach berlin
theo koll zur pandemie lage die
intensivmediziner schlagen wieder alarm
die zahl der korona intensivpatienten
nehme schneller zu als erwartet
schon ende april könnten es 6000 werden
so viele wie auf dem höhepunkt der
zweiten welle
laut robert-koch-institut haben sich in
den vergangenen 24 stunden zehn 1810
menschen neu angesteckt 294 weitere sind
in verbindung mit coop 19 gestorben
die sieben tage incidents liegt bei fast
1 141 das ist der höchste wert seit
mitte januar um die dritte corona welle
zu brechen hat das kabinett nun die
bundesweite notbremse auf den weg
gebracht ziel klare und einheitliche
regeln statt flickenteppich steigt die
inzidenz über 100 so muss dann zum
beispiel die nächtliche ausgangssperre
gelten
das betreffe im moment etwa zwei drittel
der landkreise und städte
steigt der wert über 200 müssen schulen
schließen das wäre in 42 landkreisen und
städten der fall thomas reichert
berichtet
merkels entmachtung der länder im kampf
gegen das virus geht schnell an diesem
morgen das kabinett einigte sich auf
eine notbremse etwas dass merkel vor
wochen schon mit der bund länder
konferenz entschieden hat woran viele
länder sich aber nicht recht hielten
damit für die dritte welle bremsen damit
wir sie brechen damit wir sie umkehren
reichen die bisherigen bodtländer
beratung alleine nicht mehr aus sondern
muss unsere pandemie bekämpfung
stringenter konsequenter werden
bundesweit soll nun bei einer inzidenz
über 100 automatische ausgangs
beschränkungen zwischen 21 und 5 uhr
morgens gelten private zusammenkünfte
sollen pro haushalt beschränkt sein auf
nur eine weitere person nur geschäfte
für den täglichen bedarf sollen öffnen
theater museen und zoos dagegen
schließen
merkel hat gestern noch viel telefoniert
besonders mit der fdp deren stimmen sie
für eine zweidrittelmehrheit und eine
gesetzgebung im eilverfahren eigentlich
brauchte ebenso wie afg und linke aber
lehnt die fdp das paket ab wir fallen im
prinzip auf einen technischen stand und
auf einen wissensstand wie zu beginn der
pandemie zurück und das ist nach einem
jahr ein schwerer mangel des entwurfs
besonders kritisiert die ausgangssperren
dabei sehen forscher das
infektionsrisiko und freien als sehr
gering an
es ist unerklärlich dass es im privaten
bereich härteste sanktionen und härteste
restriktionen gibt während es im bereich
der wirtschaft bei den unternehmen immer
noch viele empfehlungen gibt wegen
dieser widerstände dauert es nun länger
nächste woche soll der bundestag dann
mit einfacher mehrheit das paket
beschließen
private firmen und behörden müssen ihren
mitarbeitern künftig corona tests
anbieten auch das beschloss das kabinett
heute bisher bekämen nur rund zehn nur
rund sechs von zehn beschäftigten ein
testangebot von ihren arbeitgebern sagt
arbeitsminister heil das reiche nicht
ein finanzieller ausgleich für die
unternehmen ist nicht geplant florian
kojak hat mehr
beim thüringer automobilzulieferer tm
können sich die mitarbeiter kostenlos
testen
schon jetzt zweimal pro woche vor
schichtbeginn ein angebot das von so gut
wie allen hier dankbar angenommen wird
ich finde es sehr gut weil es auch eine
sicherheit gibt dass man auch ein
sicheres gefühl auf arbeit hat und
allgemein dann auch der umgang mit den
kollegen viel entspannender läuft sehr
vorteil ist dass man gewissheit bekommt
ob man positiv ist oder nicht und somit
dann auch für die angehörigen zu hause
die sicherheit hat das unternehmen nun
dazu verpflichtet werden tests für ihre
mitarbeiter anzubieten und auch die
kosten dafür tragen müssen kritisieren
arbeitgeberverbände
die wirtschaft läuft jetzt so langsam
wieder an und jetzt über zusatzkosten
diese situation zu belasten halte ich
für eine völlig falsche gangart die die
bundesregierung hier einschlägt 450
mitarbeiter hat etm in salwik testet
sich jeder von ihnen regelmäßig kostet
das das unternehmen 20.000 euro pro
monat
die nachteile sind natürlich die kosten
die wir so in keiner form geplant haben
für uns habe ich frühzeitig entschieden
dass wir diese tests er eigenständig
durchführen um einfach die positiven
effekte durch das frühzeitige erkennen
von infektionen zu erhalten
mit erfolg zwei positive fälle konnten
sie so bereits identifizieren und damit
verhindern dass sich das virus
ausbreitet innerhalb der belegschaft
nächster rückschlag für die deutsche
impfkampagne der us-konzern johnson &
johnson hat den marktstart seines
mittels in europa verschoben
zuvor waren in den usa in sechs fällen
blutgerinnsel nach der verschiffung
aufgetreten
der impfstoff ist seit mitte märz in der
eben zugelassen die ersten dosen sind
heute in deutschland angekommen und zehn
millionen sollen bis ende juni geliefert
werden das sind circa 15 prozent der
gesamten impfstoffmenge in deutschland
bis mitte des jahres vor dem
gesundheitsministerium in washington
steht elmar theveßen immer welches
risiko birgt dieser impfstoff welche
erfahrungen haben die usa damit gemacht
ja in den usa sind bisher etwa sieben
millionen dosen von diesem impfstoff von
johnson & johnson verimpft worden und
dabei gab es in sechs fällen
komplikationen
es betraf dann sechs frauen im alter
zwischen 18 und 48 jahren eine person
ist gestorben die anderen sind noch in
behandlung und das was als ergebnis da
ist diese komplikationen das sind
blutgerinnsel in den gehirnen also
vergleichbar mit dem was wir auch in den
letzten wochen und monaten bei
astrazeneca in europa und anderswo
erlebt haben die behörden hier in den
usa sagen ganz klar das betrifft erst
mal nur johnson & johnson hier
es gibt nichts vergleichbares bei den
impfstoffen von biotech und auch
moderner und deswegen hat er seine keine
ganz so große relevanz in den usa denn
der johnson & johnson impfstoff stellt
etwa nur fünf prozent an den impfungen
hier
bisher sind in den usa über 120
millionen menschen bereits geimpft
worden aber für europa ist das relevant
denn die gesamte europäische union
erwartet lieferungen von johnson &
johnson bis ende juni sollen das 55
millionen impfdosen seien
und jetzt muss eben geklärt werden was
diese verzögerung diese prüfung in den
nächsten wochen und monaten für die im
strategie in europa bedeutet dankeschön
washington dts us präsident joe biden
will offenbar die amerikanischen truppen
noch in diesem jahr aus afghanistan
abziehen
das berichten medien mit berufung auf
regierungskreise
der abzug solle am symbolträchtigen
elfter september abgeschlossen sein
allerdings müssten bestimmte sicherheits
zusagen erfüllt sein
die verbündeten der amerikaner darunter
auch deutschland sollen offiziell morgen
informiert werden und als erstes
mitglied der neuen us-regierung ist
verteidigungsminister osten nach
deutschland gereist im gespräch mit
seiner kollegin kramp karrenbauer
erklärte osten dass die usa 500
zusätzliche soldatinnen und soldaten in
deutschland stationieren werden
eine kehrtwende denn der ehemalige
us-präsident wollte aus deutschland
eigentlich noch 12.000 frauen und männer
ab zu die fdp hat ihre weichen für die
bundestagswahl gestellt statt auf so
wörtlich stabs frömmigkeit wollen die
liberalen in ihrem programm auf
individuelle verantwortung setzen auf
mögliche bündnispartner will man sich
noch nicht festlegen
kubald nie gab es mehr zu tun findet die
fdp und zieht mit dieser losung den
wahlkampf ziel für den herbst wieder
mitregieren in welcher koalition bleibt
offen
das hänge von inhalten ab nicht von
personen bei der union ist für uns nicht
die spannende frage wer am ende der
kanzlerkandidat sein wird sondern was
der inhalt des programms sein soll
die fdp will bürokratie abbauen
digitalisierung voranbringen und bessere
bildung sie verspricht keine
steuererhöhungen außer für digital
konzerne wie google oder facebook
klimaschutz will die fdp technologie
offen gestalten und marktorientiert die
ökologische transformation sie kann eine
gefahr für die arbeitsplätze für den
sozialen zusammenhalt in unserer
gesellschaft sein sie kann aber auch
eine chance für unsere gesellschaft sein
sie kann zum wohlstands faktor werden
und die den klimaschutz durch ein
striktes co2 limit für alle sektoren
effektiv zu gestalten das haben wir uns
in unserem programm vorgenommen
die fdp setze nicht auf einen starken
staat sondern vertraue auf die menschen
im prinzip ein starkes land mit
menschen die viel potenzial haben die
zeigen wollen was in ihnen steckt aber
unser staatliches gemeinwesen ist leider
ein sanierungsfall
so wie es ist dürfte es nicht bleiben
sagt linden ob und wie die fdp in einer
neuen koalition aber gebraucht wird ist
bisher kaum absehbar
bürgerkriegsähnliche zustände das war
offenbar das ziel der sogenannten gruppe
es eine rechts terroristische
vereinigung benannt nach ihrem
mutmaßlichen rädelsführer werner es
zwölf männer die sich nun vor dem
oberlandesgericht stuttgart verantworten
müssen ihm wird vorgeworfen anschläge
auf moscheen und politiker geplant zu
haben
günther neufeld berichtet stuttgart
stammheim ein hoch gesicherten
gerichtsgebäude einst gebaut für die
prozesse gegen die terroristen der
linken rote armee fraktion jetzt geht es
hier um rechtsradikale gewalt auf der
anklagebank elf männer die eine
terroristische vereinigung gebildet
haben sollen und einer der sie
unterstützt haben soll so der vorwurf
der bundesanwaltschaft tödliche
anschläge auf moscheen
hier sollen sich die mitglieder der
gruppe 2009 10 zum ersten mal persönlich
getroffen haben auf einem grillplatz in
baden württemberg die männer zwischen 30
und anfang 60 wohnten in sechs
verschiedenen bundesländern über chat
gruppen blieben sie in verbindung einige
waren zuvor schon in der rechtsradikalen
szene aktiv gewesen in organisationen
mit namen wie freikorps heimatschutz
oder wo das erben germanien neonazis
mitglieder von bürgerwehren reichs
bürger und anhänger als germanischer
gottheiten alle versammelten sich in der
gruppe es ihr ziel offenbar der
politische umsturz in deutschland im
februar 2020 schlug die polizei zu
durchsuchte bundesweit 53 objekte nahm
13 verdächtige fest einer aus der gruppe
hatte sich an die behörden
konkrete planungen für bestimmte
anschläge gab es noch nicht wie
gefährlich die gruppe war die nächsten
monate vor gericht werden es zeigen
zum zweiten mal beginnt für fast zwei
milliarden muslime weltweit der
fastenmonat ramadan unter corona
bedingungen von der morgendämmerung bis
sonnenuntergang heißt es unter anderem
nichts essen und nichts trinken das
gemeinsame fastenbrechen und beten am
abend muss nun wieder corona gerecht
gestaltet werden gebete in der moschee
gehen nur mit abstand auch in
deutschland in arbeit es hat mir der
zeitplan hängt am kühlschrank heute
dürfen sie neben mutter vier kaffees von
fünf uhr morgens bis halb neun abends
nichts essen und trinken manche muslime
lassen sich im ramadan auch nicht impfen
das frühstück bei cafés sozusagen mitten
in der nacht
aber man muss dadurch wohl eher hoch
eigentlich treffen sie abends familie
und viele freunde
das muss jetzt ausfallen immerhin die
moscheen sind offen für uns ist das so
ein monat wo wir unseren glauben noch
einmal stärken können und wo wir die
möglichkeit haben unsere sünden nochmal
zu bereinigen und das ist für uns an
etwas sehr schönes
jeder muss sich registrieren und
desinfizieren und den eigenen teppich
mitbringen die liegen auf markierungen
ein meter fünfzig abstand dass es
vorwürfe gibt muslime hätten die regel
nicht ein ärgert viele das sind
gefährliche spekulationen die eigentlich
geeignet sind einen keil zwischen die
gesellschaft zu betreiben
insofern wir sehen seit über einem jahr
dass insbesondere in den moscheen die
menschen sich vorbildlich an alle
vorgaben halten
viele senioren kommen derzeit nicht in
die moschee
sie haben angst auch weil die alte
heimat türkei sehr viele infizierte
meldet es ist der zweite ramadan in
corona zeiten für die rund fünf
millionen muslime in deutschland der
wichtigste monat des jahres und jetzt
fußball-bundesliga norbert schon wieder
ein trainerwechsel gestern köln heute
frankfurt eintracht trainer adi hütter
wird nun doch nächste saison in gladbach
arbeiten deren coach marco rose geht ja
zum bvb frankfurt um angeblich 7,5
millionen euro ablöse reicher aber um
einen spitzen trainer hermann unter adi
hütter gelingt der eintracht ihre bisher
beste bundesliga saison mit guten
chancen auf die erste champions league
qualifikation der vereinsgeschichte
trotzdem hat hütter offenbar geködert
vom umtriebigen gladbacher sportdirektor
max eberl den weg aus dem taunus an den
niederrhein gewählt die entscheidung zur
neuen saison ein neues kapitel
aufzuschlagen habe ich mir nicht leicht
gemacht alles was für mich jetzt zählt
ist der erfolg der eintracht im
trainerkarussell folgt der österreicher
in mönchengladbach auf marco rose denen
es im sommer nach dortmund sieht auch
der zeitpunkt der wechsel bekanntgabe
kommt überraschend denn am samstag
trifft hüther mit der eintracht in
mönchengladbach ausgerechnet auf seinen
neuen arbeitgeber
heute abend münchen morgen abend
dortmund zwei deutsche vereine kämpfen
um den einzug ins champions league
halbfinale
das hinspiel gegen manchester city das
hatte der bvb nur knapp mit 1 2 verloren
ja und hofft jetzt auf eine magische
fußball-nacht in dortmund vor genau
einer woche mit dem schlusspfiff in
manchester hat edin terzic angefangen an
das unmögliche zu glauben da wusste er
noch nicht dass hinter seinem hinspiel
torschützen reus im moment noch ein
einsatz fragezeichen stehen würde
genauso wie hinter abwehrchef mats
hummels es wird eine brutal schwere
aufgabe das ist klar aber der glaube ist
groß der glaube wird dennoch nicht
reichen sondern harte arbeit und mut das
sind die die kennzeichen die morgen den
ausschlag geben können der
tabellenführer der englischen premier
league ist zuletzt dreimal im
viertelfinale ausgeschieden dortmund
hätte nichts dagegen diese serie morgen
fortzusetzen
die dfb-frauen haben norwegen in einem
freundschaftsspiel wiesbaden besiegt
nach der frühen gästeführung der rasche
ausgleich durch laura freigang und nach
linda dallmann erhöhte schließlich
paulina krumbiegel in der 61 minute zum
3 1-endstand für das deutsche team
das was von mir zum schluss noch eine
ausstellung mit gänsehautgarantie in
russland genauer im weißen meer
wer dabei sein will muss kälte mögen und
abtauchen unter meist an fotografien und
skulpturen von lebewesen aus dem
nordmeer zu sehen vom aussterben bedroht
sollte der klimawandel voranschreitet
kreative warnung mit tiefgang hier
sozusagen das kühle april wetter bleibt
uns auch morgen erhalten erst mit sonne
dann mit schauern mehr hat gleich katja
hornuf bettina schausten begrüßt sehen
heute journal um viertel vor zehn und
wir sind morgen wieder da danke dass sie
dabei waren einen schönen abend noch und
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren zum klassischen
aprilwetter gehören strahlender
sonnenschein blauer himmel und jede
menge schauer regenschauer
schneeregenschauer schneeschauer graupel
gewitter und tiefe temperaturen
aktuell liegen die temperaturen und etwa
drei oder vier grad unter dem was wir in
den vergangenen 30 jahren so
üblicherweise anfang april erleben
dürfen auch heute nacht ist es meist
klar und deswegen sinken die
temperaturen hier in süddeutschland auf
minus zwei bis minus 7 grad im norden
sind es um minus ein bis minus 4 grad
frostfrei bleibt aber nur an den küsten
von ost und nordsee und die
höchsttemperaturen morgen legen ähnlich
wie heute zwischen 4 grad im
westerzgebirge und 10 grad am rhein
der vormittag beginnt erstmal mit sehr
viel sonnenschein aber an der nordsee
kommen schon die ersten schauer heran
und die breiten sich im laufe des
nachmittags weiter richtung sachsen aus
da sind auch mal gewitter dabei und in
den mittelgebirgen kann auch schnee
dabei sein
auch im schwarzwald sind einige
schneeregenschauer nicht ganz
ausgeschlossen
der donnerstag bringt noch wenig
wetteränderung aber freitag und samstag
werden dann meist trocken sein und es
wird ein kleines bisschen milder mit 6
bis 14 grad am samstag schönen abend
noch